And how are you, Cristian Casares greets you
with his brief News Now report in
Spanish? Detectives continue to
investigate an accident on Rainbow
near Flamingo.
they were on the street and made
it stop between the two crashed vehicles
las vegas firefighters and rescuers
worked this morning on a
reported fire in a vacant apartment
near downtown and charleston casinos
this incident occurred at 550 in the
morning no reports were made  injured
one of the largest auto conventions in
the world is happening here
in las vegas' it's all about top and thanks
to this convention thousands of tourists are expected to visit
the
las vegas convention center there will be a
variety of new products for
cars with the focus this year on
electronic vehicles
and we close with the weather forecast
we will have a d  It was a sunny day with
temperatures reaching 76 degrees
by the afternoon we will see a slight increase
reaching 80 degrees by Thursday
but then they will drop for the weekend
I am Cristian Cásseres with his brief
news now in Spanish good
day
[Music]